-Here at "Late Night,"
every night,
I deliver a monologue
comprised of jokes
written by
a diverse team of writers.
As a result, a lot of jokes
come across my desk that,
due to my being
a straight white male,
it would be difficult
for me to deliver.
But we don't think that should
stop you from enjoying them,
so we'd like
to share them with you now
in a segment called
"Jokes Seth Can't Tell."
[ Cheers and applause ]
These are two of our writers,
Amber and Jenny.
-I'm black!
-And I'm gay!
-And we're both women.
-And I'm not,
so here's how this works.
I'll read the setups
for these jokes,
and Amber and Jenny
will read the punch lines.
Here we go.
Scientists are mourning
after the world's
last male northern white rhino
has died.
-Meanwhile,
black rhinos die every day,
and nobody says [bleep]
[ Laughter and applause ]
-The San Francisco Bay Area
recently hosted a conference
for lesbians
involved in the tech industry.
-"Hey, I have that Polo shirt!"
said everyone to everyone else.
[ Laughter ]
-Jenny, what's
the most popular thing
on display at
a lesbian tech conference?
-That haircut.
-All right.
[ Laughter ]
-"Air & Space Magazine"
recently published an article
about a historical event known
as the Black Christmas Disaster.
-It's about the time my family
ran out of sweet-potato pie.
[ Laughter ]
Just kidding --
that has never happened.
My mom has five or six
in the freezer right now
just in case I get sad.
[ Laughter ]
-A library in Chicago
will host an exhibit next month
called Gay is Good.
-It's expected to be
unpopular with Trump supporters
because it's in a library.
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
-"The Washington Post"
recently published an article
about a little-known type
of wine called black wine.
-Or as it's more commonly known
"caber-nae-nae."
[ Laughter ]
-The Vatican
recently refused to host
an International Women's Day
conference
because one of the speakers
was a lesbian.
-And because they're too busy
hosting a 2,000-year-long
pedophile convention.
[ Audience groans, laughter ]
-Now, wait.
Jenny, are you Catholic?
-I am.
-Huh. I've never seen
a gay Catholic.
-Oh.
Have you looked in the closet?
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
All right,
we've got one more joke.
Who's gonna take it?
-Neither of us.
We're tired.
-But we brought a friend
to help us.
Come on out!
-Hey!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Tiffany Haddish, everyone!
-Whoo!
I am!
-All right!
Here we go.
-I am Tiffany.
Yes, I am, and thank you for
being able to tell us apart.
[ Laughter ]
-I just tried to remember,
Amber, right.
[ Laughter ]
All right, so here we go.
Denzel Washington will appear
on Broadway next month
in the classic play
"The Iceman Cometh."
-And the women in the audience
will also cometh.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-That was great.
Very well done, very well done.
-Hey, Seth.
Why don't you tell one?
-No, I-I couldn't.
I couldn't.
-Come on, tell one.
-No, I feel like
if I tell one of these,
I'm gonna get in trouble.
-Oh, just do it!
-Okay, okay!
I trust you guys.
-Okay, yeah.
A new study has found
that the average mom
gets one hour and seven minutes
of time to herself every day,
and she uses it to complain.
-How dare you!
-She just had your baby!
-You told me it would be okay!
-I'm shocked.
I'm shocked!
-In a lobby!
-You lied to me!
-You're a bad man!
Black women
and lesbians are liars!
[ Cheers and applause ]